the incentive structure is set up for  short-term gain without consideration  for the long-term implications because  when you look at some of the largest if  not the vast majority of the largest  problems that we face whether it's world  hunger or  you know climate collapse we actually  have everything we need right now to  solve those problems the impediments are  all human or human constructed  and a lot of them track back to the  incentive structures that we've created  that drive bad decisions for long-term  solutions yep politics we have election  cycles raise money get into office and  it's all about you know making sure you  stay in office quarterly earnings like  you know everything right without  eradicating those incentive structures  and building better ones we're sort of  shouldering it as individuals that's not  going to solve it you know we need both  that grassroots individual shift as well  as institutional revolution really